[Music]
the summer of 2004 was a really fun one
and a really successful one career-wise
for me if i do say so myself yeah i got
offered a movie that um sounded like it
would be fun to do i met with the star
of the movie lindsay lohan i guess i
passed is it past muster or past mustard
i think it's past muster past muster ips
muster i don't know if you have to say
either i know i shouldn't have said i
shouldn't even try why are we doing
these old-fashioned sayings anyway well
you're no spring chicken i know okay so
lindsay approved of me that the muster
was passed very kindly she invited me
out to get to know one another and so i
i went out with her i met her at her
house with her i'll say entourage she
had a bunch of people there and we all
piled into this enormous suv so i'm
sitting next to
a woman i said so how do you know
lindsay and she said do you see you know
her sidekick for the younger listeners
it was kind of like a an iphone you put
text on and stuff and i said yeah she
said uh well you know how it's jeweled i
did that and you see her uh purse with
the jewels on it i did that and i said
oh so you be dazzled those things and
she got
kind of offended she corrected me and
said no no i and i forget what she
corrected me with but it was like an
accessory jewelerist or something well i
would have preferred badass yeah
accessory jewelries and i felt like i
had
offended her i apologize of course but
to this day i still wouldn't know what
to call her speaking of bedazzling let's
be dazzled people's ears
life could be a dream
life could be a dream
[Music]
you're listening to life is short i'm
your host justin long life could be a
dream sweetheart
with me as always is my also uh bedazzle
uh unfamiliar
i've never owned anything that has been
bedazzled you haven't maybe you have
like a little tchotchke
like what i don't know um
oh man this is a tough one um but anyway
i yeah the bedazzler was big for a while
i remember and weren't women getting
their pants bedazzled wasn't that part
of it i was gonna go a step further
yeah yeah you always go right from
bedazzling to jazz i don't picture it
but i think about it i've never seen one
a bedazzled vagina or a potassium
um i made just like a really weird
admission
do you know why i'm red maybe because i
just ate two zots and i'm sweating
because they're so intense and sour look
at how much i'm sweating from them you
are you're you're really yeah it's not
because of the vagina are you allergic
to zots by the way what i hope not what
a throwback episode so far yes so why
are we talking about zots why are we
talking about
the jazzlers or bedazzlers
well because um
it started with lindsay lohan that's
right not to connect her to directly to
all of those things but um her a member
of her entourage was it was a bit
uh a high-class bedazzle that's right
and who else was a member of her
entourage back in those days well he was
in the car that night because they were
they were dating um our guest today
uh is lindsay's former bodyguard no is
uh lindsay's former boyfriend um now
happily married with a with a baby what
if he's married well happily together
together
in a mating in a monogamous yes coupling
yes well coupling yes uh our guest today
is
wilmer valderrama and i think that is
the worst interactive words he has ever
received in his career oh wilmer's great
and he's i hope he's laughing i hope
he's listening so our guest today wilmer
not only is lindsay lohan's former lover
he's a very accomplished man in his own
right he was on of course that 70s show
for years played fez uh he arguably i
think he was the funniest part of that
show um now he is one of the stars of
the hugely popular hit show biggest show
in the world yeah ncis he does so many
things he does music and he's a producer
yeah he does everything and now he's a
father which most importantly he's also
just like a great guy he really helped
me out a lot when we were doing herbie
because um you know it's one of those
big budget movies and a lot of effects
and waiting around and i loved when he'd
come to visit set because we had so much
fun palling around uh we talk about that
among other things uh all the stuff he
has going on and about fatherhood let's
hear it let's do it my ketchup with my
old pal
wilmer valderrama
life could be a dream sweetheart
[Music]
will finishing justin wilm wilm
that's stupid where where are you you
look great
thank you man i'm in my office at home
um
in i built a little office here in my
house because
i wanted to spend as much time at home
as possible after after working you know
and then working some more from home
well especially
because you have a kid you have an
adorable i mean i'm guessing it's
adorable pretty adorable not as adorable
as you would think you know
i've always wondered because i knew one
day you'd have an adorable um
how old
is the baby now so it's a baby girl
baby girl she is about to be i think
she's actually two months
on thursday okay so she was born uh
february 15 which is a crazy journey
just to talk about that but
but it's been it's been amazing you know
the first three weeks um amanda and i
uh amanda's my fiancee we did
you know we kind of did it on our own
right i mean i was able to get a bunch
of days off from shooting or whatever so
i was able to be home and stuff so we
did everything on our own well you mean
you had the birth on your own the the
yeah like i pushed it out and she
carried it you know right no
no i'm talking about i'm talking about
like meaning like you don't have any
help you come home with the baby right
and then you have to you know all night
every day every two and a half hours
you're feeding the baby yeah this is the
biggest word of advice i can give any
dad is that on that first week or two
weeks
um
if you think that it's all about the
woman doing most of the work because
most guys will tell you you know they
really are the ones that you know have
to do most of the work the truth is it's
not true like there is a major
contribution that men should really have
in that in that process in that time
period and
what would be the top of that list like
what if you were to describe to somebody
well here are the things that you had to
do
feed your woman and keep her hydrated
because she will forget to eat she will
forget to drink water and it's so
it's like it's like such a small obvious
thing but you wouldn't even think of it
because you feed yourself right i'm
thirsty i'll go drink the water i'm
hungry i'll go get my meal you know but
when someone is feeding a child for
every two and a half hours you know and
you only have maybe another two and
maybe an hour and a half or two hours to
take a nap you choose the nap over evie
yeah sure of course you know because
you're sleep deprivation and stuff so so
it's you know that was the biggest thing
for me to learn that man like two days
did somebody tell you that will or is
that something that you just those are
things that like you know when it
happens you just learn on the on the fly
i think it's when it happens you start
noticing
wait i just ate and she did it
you know
in that kind of like primal situation
where you start thinking like oh man
this is there's something bigger going
on here and i think really got to pay
attention to all these little things you
know and
and i and i think that that i would say
that's number one keeping your
your partner um fed and hydrated you
know they have a lot to do right i mean
they have to
you know emotionally be available for
the baby to to bond and also feed the
baby and you know my my girl uh my
fiance was you know she was
just unbelievable it was such a natural
and like everything woke up for her and
she was just she just knew what to do um
was she nervous was dreaming really
appreciated were you nervous together
beforehand because it's it's your it's a
first for both of you so was it like
yeah what the f what's on the horizon
yeah yeah yeah like especially when it's
your first one uh because
now that i have a second one but on the
first one i what i
what i can tell you is
you know people are going to everyone
that has a baby will have their own
version of a success and failure story
okay and they lead with the failure
story right so they'll scare that [ __ ]
out of you first and then they'll tell
you but you're going to be fine yeah why
you're like what is that instinct is it
like because i've noticed this with
parents and people who have gone through
things
um
what is that instinct to be like this is
the i had to do this so you know get
ready a friend of mine had just had a
second one and she sees kids that
there's parents at the park with
with their little kids and they're
pregnant and she thinks i want to say
she said i want to say to them like oh
you're in for it you really are in for
it and i wonder what that instinct is
like um
is there is there a like a sense of
pride that that they have like i went
through this and
i guess survived it and good luck you
surviving it too you know
yeah
it's it's it's um i'm about you know
seven and a half weeks in right i mean
she's about to be two months old you
know six months into it into the
pregnancy and the part once you tell
some friends and selectively you know
you know a family and select the friends
you know the tsunami of advice that you
didn't ask for yes you know kind of it's
offered right well you have a big family
too so you must have heard from all of
your
[Music]
immediate family you know it's funny
like my mom and my dad were hilarious
because they're that old school like
colombian venezuelan parents who grew up
in south america without
any of the technology or advances in
toys distractions and bottles yeah
diapers and like all of that stuff yeah
um so for them was like
uh just have the kid like i don't know
what it was to tell you you know
it was pretty easy that that's
interesting how different your
their experience was and how different
you grew up um
are there parts of that
experience that you had that you want to
make sure that you want to make an
effort to instill
in the raising of your
of your child of your daughter um and if
so which what are they and
is there a part of you that thinks oh my
god she's gonna have access to too many
things like i am who i am because i was
raised a certain way and and
right maybe it's a very intuitive
question man because a lot woke up in me
as soon as i held the baby like
i don't know why but the first thing
that came to my mind is when do i
introduce the phone
when do i introduce a tablet right like
that was the first thing that came to
mind because
here we're doing this primal physical
bonding with the baby yeah and right now
it's about the baby and you and at some
point you will introduce
something that will take a different
level of bonding away and that bonding
is going to be redistributed into a new
level of information right and that
information may be more stimulating than
your parents at some point totally so so
so you think about that question and you
go man like what what is the thing you
know and i think it's about delaying it
as much as possible
i believe
until
i mean this is just my concept we'll see
obviously you gotta take day by day
everything falls as it goes you know you
find who you are as a parent away from
your parents
uh based on what you've learned in your
personal journey there is tons of things
that my parents did that i would be like
i'll never do that with my kids you know
and then there is a tons of things that
my parents did that i was like meh like
that right
well what's something that you'd really
want to impart that they did for you
i i you know i know it sounds gonna be
really silly but
but um
my mom taught me how to dance at like
five six years old
and that was a moment that i'll never
forget with my mother huh right so like
dancing with my mother
you know during those times when she was
cleaning and the song would play and
then i would see her like move and i'd
be like what is that it should be like
do it like this
and i and learning how to dance early
um really made me comfortable with my
body for my sisters too right like and
and now mind you like it doesn't matter
what type of dance right like we're all
obviously you're gonna fish for a
six-year-old kid like moving his hips
like crazy because i'm venezuelan yeah
you know what i mean but but it's not
that different from adult damage it's
not that different and justin what i was
gonna say especially the way i dance
which by the way it's a wonderous
experience he's like wise i've seen you
there yeah thank you thank you um
i think the point is
i said to myself learn how to uh dance
and swim defend yourself in that order
hmm dance you know defend yourself okay
the swimming and dancing can go even
hand in hand a little bit you know but i
think they're defending yourself for
example like the company you know i have
a daughter right and she's entering a
world where i feel like intentions are
for a more forward than ever before
there was a tradition of
of the interaction between a young man
and a young woman you know now it's a
whole different thing right like i i
myself have a tough time understanding
and i think that um having the
confidence of knowing you know you can
have your own back as well i think
that's important in terms of interacting
you want to give her those tools to
interact properly with guy with boys
with men yeah i mean i think that she i
think we as as men have a responsibility
to you know to show our young daughters
through the experience of showing them
how you are with your wife what they see
is what they make and eventually will
mirror their future relationships
and if communication is the first thing
they see then that would be the first
phase of you know of solving a problem
did you have a good example of that
growing up no uh-huh huh
right so so that's like another thing
where like my mom would bottle up stuff
you know my dad would
just bring more flowers
you know yeah so i would be like a
funeral parlor that's right
yeah
yeah it's a different generation that
will
yeah it is a different generation
because at that time you know nobody
taught you how to talk how to speak your
feelings i mean look for all of us it
doesn't even matter culturally right
because even culturally for us as
expressive as we are when it comes to
avoiding
uh vulnerability um that was a skill
avoid vulnerability you're not allowed
to be vulnerable right especially as a
young man
as a latino totally
that's something that you guys did
mind a lot on
you found a lot of comedic potential in
that on that 70s show i feel like fez
was a very sensitive
kid right and um yeah and and it was i
which is why they cast me yeah oh really
yeah
well maybe i mean like you've always
struck me as being
in touch with
i don't want to call it a feminine side
now because we that's how we grew up we
labeled it no but it is i mean it is it
is because i know i know that people are
very shy over
you know the the vocabulary and the the
actual infrastructure and blueprint and
how we we expressed what that was back
then but i really do think it's a
feminine side because
you know my mother was the one who i saw
from the moment i woke up to most of the
times where a moment i went to sleep
right so i'm talking about the entire
day and you have an older sister
ernie yeah and i have two sisters right
well i'm a year older but we're so close
that we really had a real friendship you
know and you know maryland right so
yeah so so the the point is is
is that you know you have your mom
you have your sister there's a year
younger and then you have the baby of
the house right which is another girl
and having the the infrastructure to be
able to communicate and know what is
proper and what is respectful um that
early i think is part of you being in
tune with
you know the other sides um you know uh
thoughts and thinking and well-being and
all of that and being the older
son i had the role of protecting but
also having to be
emotionally available
for however they want to communicate
with me i gave me an edge growing up of
really understanding how to communicate
with everyone right like i mean i know
it didn't matter if it's just women or
men you know i think that that really
helped that what what form did that
usually take will like when you you say
you had to be there emotionally for the
women in your house how
what's an example of that if you were to
give for example like if my sister was
you know uh you know i'm half making
this up in half yeah
you know going back to real memories but
you know it's kind of like when
when a boy would make fun of your sister
you know
there's three things that go through
your mind
as the
male son right first thing is i gotta
beat this person up right like that's
like the first thing that your dad
teaches you you gotta defend your family
you know as a last man right and then
and then the second thing is like
you know really understand like you
can't just
wash it off right so i kind of just
skipped like the whole oh i gotta beat
this guy up for me it was about
listening to my sister why she was upset
by this you know um and that was the
first thing it was about understanding
what about that incident really hurt her
and where was that hurt yeah you know
like what what was that like how do we
fix that yeah because this is gonna
happen in life yeah how do we fix this
first right well then there's the idea
of justice i mean you know that's the
other thing it's like you start there
are all these concepts that we now take
for granted
that you have to that your daughter now
is going to have to
learn that must be that's
that'd blow my mind
justice like oh it's not fair
yeah and i think that for everything
that's not fair because look man i
i go back to also some of my my true
experiences justin
in the industry at all right like i mean
the way that
you know i experienced you know so much
in such a high school cafeteria which we
worked in for 20 years right you and i
totally and you think about how like it
just doesn't grow right like it's like
you know everyone kind of gets in this
suspended universe where all of a sudden
everyone's still the same age
based on when you started yeah i started
at 17 years old i'm not saying i'm the
same 17 year old obviously i'm 41 now
and i am a grown man you know but
there is something about our industry
that freezes us in time yeah and when
you talk about the word affair
there's two things that i feel you can
go about it you can either see something
as unfair
or you can see it as the commute of
differences what i call the commute of
differences based of me and what i hope
that i can teach my daughter is that if
someone has to go in that swing before
you then maybe they want it more than
you
and no matter how much you want it if
this person is willing to just get in
front of you to do it or whatever your
time is going to come this is something
that i'm really interested in that
somebody who grew up the way you did
without the same means um your
daughter's now going to be raised
let's face it she's going to have a lot
more things she's going to have access
to things do you think that that that
lesson might be harder to teach her
for sure i mean my
my lady and i you know talk about that
you know a lot more in the last i think
the last two weeks because we started
really seeing her like
you know making eye contact
communicating and smiling
yeah and also seeing that
oh
she's coming
she's on her way yeah you know and i can
we can see her the smiles and the
dimples and all that and you start
realizing oh she's the human is waking
up it's not just like this little bundle
of yeah just like a blob of [ __ ] and
food yeah it's just a little bit just
changing diapers and you put in here
and you wake up the next morning now
she's just you know now you say nakano
and she's like wow and you're like oh
she's she's aware she hears me
she's awake what's her name will
nakano oh he had nakano nakano is
japanese and uh one of the biggest
reasons uh was when
her mom and i met
we traveled the world together you know
and immediately we threw ourselves in
the deep end because we were like is
either a friendship or
this is it sorry to interrupt did you
have that mentality because um of how
instantly you connected and hit it off
you were just like
yes i think it was a combination right a
combination of where i was in my life
right and where and where she was in her
life you know and the idea that we were
okay with being alone and we were happy
to be alone yeah and that you know and
that we were gonna embark into this
you know conversation of what are we
that you see whether they're gonna be
either one or the other and i really
wasn't open for just like
you know oh i'm gonna date knowing that
this may or may not be
right i just wasn't open to that i hear
you i feel i feel you it's also like
you reach a certain age you start i
start looking at time differently it's
like i don't have the time to [ __ ]
around like that's right yeah yeah yeah
that's right
and and to your point i mean i think
it comes the distribution of time that
if you're gonna be alone i'd much rather
be obsessed over building the
infrastructure for my artistry and my
career and being creative and all of
that and that takes also emotional
availability you finding that now
difficult to balance the two i mean is
it like i mean right now must be
different right now it must be all
focused not on your little daughter
you know i don't want to sound like the
like the hallmark card but you know when
when you build a foundation off the bat
you put all your intentions into making
something work like if your intention is
for something to work if your intention
is for something to be easy on you
then you will pave a road that will be a
smooth coast into many things now there
will be obstacles there will be things
there will be distractions there'll be
other stuff that that that can pollute
the harmony and the smoothness of that
road but i truly believe in my you know
25 years in the industry and you know 41
years of life
what i have found is the is the
boundaries and the rules that you set
for yourself from the beginning it's not
like we are going to
in our road we're going to compromise
with the things that i am and the things
that you are then we're going to find a
way to really relate to the things that
we can even though we may or may not be
different from one another we may be the
same person you may be the fixer and she
may be the you know she wants saving or
like or so you may be the she may be the
savior and you may be the fixer offered
like in in this generation of
of like who am i
you know it's really important that you
i think understand
that um
you know what what whatever you really
want you have to make a conscious
decision that that is what you want you
came up during a time where you were
still adjusting to life as an actor you
came up
during a time where you were still
probably adjusting to life in america um
how did those two things coincide like
how how did you
you're still i would imagine
learning english even you know as a
teenager yeah dude i mean like
it's so crazy you asked that question
you took me back to this one specific
memory
um
where
you know i was auditioning for
you know that seven injury my dad
you know what's in that hallway with me
and it took me back to this moment
because
you know
i could barely take direction right like
this was one of my i was 17 about to
turn 18 years old i just decided to do
this acting thing two years before that
i had done a bunch of commercials a
couple of high school plays
and and i i think that i i believed in
myself i knew that but i never looked at
myself as um
i don't know what i had the audacity of
thinking
that i was no different than anyone else
in a universe where we where i was well
we were you
i imagine you were were you but were you
like a really outgoing
kid were you were you performing i was
just
you know i mean look by the way just for
all your fans and all your listeners
you know
um
i will tell you like justin and i have
known each other at
the most
adventurous times of our careers where
we just
we had all these spurts of moments and
and roller coasters professionally with
all the projects we did
and uh so i was my dog protecting me of
course
protecting sir you know we i was i was
trying to navigate
you know being a a a
high school student right and i was
still in high school when i got that 70s
show crazy and i was still going back to
high school when i had our weeks off
because remember when we did sitcoms
you'll be on two weeks off one three
weeks off one and during those off weeks
i would be at regular high school
and
so i was still adjusting with that and
you know kids could be so cruel when i
was doing the service i was so excited
i'm like oh i'm on that 70s show and
people be like why are you why don't you
sound like that why are you not the cute
one like why are you the ugly one i was
like no it's supposed to be like funny
it's supposed to be like oh they would
they would get me even in a i'm
surprised that even in la
there wasn't some there wasn't enough of
a cool factor to being on a show
wow oh i mean at that time
the uh the cool thing is if you were the
cute one remember it was the it was the
the era of heartbreaks it was the era of
the freddie prince jr so the you know
that that that era so like yeah you play
the the the silly guy on the show you're
not in that league of extraordinary
gentlemen
was it do you think that that came more
from jealousy i mean it wasn't i mean it
had to have come from jealousy i think
it's just high school you know i think
nobody wants to give you credit for
anything right in school you know right
they're not gonna
compliment your comedic timing
no yeah like upset like they would be
like wow you were brilliant
yeah that double take everybody would be
it was so cool
like dude your pants were so tight i'm
like yeah but it's like an error like
you will want to explain well will when
did it change from was it is when did it
change when did it go from being like oh
it's you you kind of get teased in
school too
you're
i would say you were cool and not cool
in a way that like
you know people might think i i always
thought you were cool because you seemed
very secure with yourself and you were
nice and and uh and you were confident
you you had a smoothness about you how
how did you cultivate that if people are
if you're going back to school and
they're teasing you
i mean it just goes to tell you in most
of our industry nobody really wants to
know who you are um they want you uh
they want you to be exactly what they
expect
right and and and
i'll leave that you know up in the
hyperspace you could really break it
down because
you know
however you break in that's how they
wanted you to stay in the 90s and the
early 2000s
you know you were the comedic relief
they didn't want to give you anything
but that you couldn't be a dramatic guy
you shouldn't do anything and not until
probably 70 show in dawson's creek
um where these two shows were the shows
where such actors were somehow a portal
to a different dimension open and these
actors were allowed to release
and all of a sudden it was like oh maybe
tv actors can do film too and to be
dramatic or whatever that was like a
very pioneering moment for a lot of
these you know that era and and you guys
all i remember your summers were always
all of you seemed busy with movies uh on
the off season we tried yeah i
specifically justin i specifically went
nuts because
i knew i just knew and i paid attention
to some of my colleagues who started
with very distinctive iconic funny
characters in sitcoms and 90s and i
ripped the page from their lesson of
saying like before this show ends i have
to establish the fact that i can do
something else
besides these boys yeah you had the
foresight to know that that could that
could have been a problem if you had
just been playing that one
yeah and it's never been done justin
like back then i mean
you know with all respect to my other
fellow actors you know like the you know
the the the say by the bells you know
the um
you know all the said comes from the
from that time if you were that
punchline character like
that was what you were and that's back
then nowadays
they're like oh an actor can do a
million things and they can be an
influencer
there's all kinds of stuff you can do
now which i'm you know i'm a different
generation i can't even dive into that
[Music]
in the early 2000s millions of
households across the world tuned in to
watch contestants battle for the last
rose or to be the final survivor on the
island reality tv was beginning to
dominate the airwaves and every show
needed to be bigger flashier more
scandalous than the last but in the case
of one infamous dating show the real
drama was happening off-screen and it
would shape the future of reality tv the
reality tv series there's something
about miriam seemed like a pretty
standard dating competition six young
men vibed for the affection of miriam
rivera a beautiful model from mexico but
when miriam revealed that she was a
trans woman during the show's finale the
on-screen drama sparked an international
uproar about gender sexuality and
whether reality television had finally
gone too far follow harsh reality the
story of miriam rivera on apple podcast
amazon music or you can listen early and
add free by joining wonder plus in apple
podcasts or the wandery app
[Music]
hello hello again
[Music]
i was thinking about fez now and like
what that character could have led to if
you had
only done if you hadn't made a concerted
effort to branch out and um
i remember talk because i was on the
show with you
and and i remember you talking about fez
you said something really interesting
about
how he was kind of a version of um
how a lot a lot of kids in your school
in back in venezuela
um saw america how they how america was
kind of fetishized in a way by by
that culture um
was that did you feel like fez ever i
mean did you ever have that feeling when
you were in america did you have a
fish out of water experience is it could
you relate to that
yeah i had a little bit of a fish out of
water experience uh but i also
experienced a different side of it like
like fez wasn't nobody really made fun
of fest we all made fun of each other
nobody demeaned fest they were just kind
of like that's crazy that came out of
your mouth you know
but but in real life you were taught to
be you know inferior because you had an
accident because if you had an accident
you were uneducated you know um there
was a lot of stereotypes that were put
on you
when you first arrived immediately they
think that you just came from dirt and
jungle and then you just in america
wearing shoes for the first time yeah
and you should be so
grateful to be here to be in this uh
modern yes like yeah like wow have you
ever have you ever had soda before and
you're like what like so kids would ask
you stuff like that oh crazy my cousins
my cousins who lived and grew up in
america i came here my dad had a brother
here then his kids you know they took us
in for like the first two weeks while we
found a place and all of them first
arrived to america
and their kids will be looking at me and
my sisters and they'd be like did you
guys have schools oh my god and we're
like uh
yeah oh my god we had schools and and
they'd be like how would you get to
school so then i'm a clown right so
immediately at 13 14 years old i'm
telling the kids
well we got tired of walking barefoot
all the way to a school for four miles
so we just ride our horse to school
every day you know and we would have to
bring up a charity and get to the jungle
so we can go through the river and then
eventually you know you come
home with you know sometimes you lose a
shirt i don't know it's tough
like they were like
whoa
well it's fun like
it's funny well i watch a lot of 90 day
fiance you know that show 90 day fiance
that's amazing but but but i found that
like um all the americans on it have
this
misconception that the
foreign people
are have always dreamed of coming to
america you know and and
and the place they're from is so
inferior to
america there's that um assumption which
which
most of the characters on that show have
and i i'm now imagining americans you
grew up with probably having a version
of that
with you
yeah i mean it was a perception right i
mean it was exactly what they put on you
and they put it on most immigrants right
yeah i think that when i
the funny thing about it justin is that
i was born in miami
so
you know so when i turned three years
old
three years old we moved back to
venezuela my dad and my mom met in miami
they married there they had myself and
my sister and then at three years so my
parents moved back to venezuela because
that's what the work was we went to work
the agriculture industry so we went back
to venezuela and i'm a citizen of the
united states because i was born in the
united states not because i nationalized
it i mean what does it call that uh
naturalized you know and became a
citizen you know
i was born in america so i've had a i
had an american passport since birth
right so i grew up in venezuela because
that's when my dad was working the
agriculture industry and back then el
bolivar which is the national coin
venezuela and the dollar were like 21.
oh my god it's not amazing
it was insane right so and the other
thing i was going to tell you is that
venezuela in natural resources it's the
number one reserve of oil in the world
then it was the third largest produce of
oil in the world so we could have been a
dubai if it wasn't for corruption and
politically and mature
yeah
holding on to it and job is
a streak of destabilization that now the
country is in a very bad place but back
then
it was thriving
like it was it was insane it was a
metropolis you know what i mean so so
leaving venezuela was ultimately uh
was it was an option for my father after
the telegraphing of a national coup
uh on the government by chavez in uh in
the early 90s wow and my dad saw that
it's like this is a bad sign there's
something kind of bad they're gonna
happen here we should probably go back
to america and then my parents decided
to leave everything and bring us to the
united states because he saw that that
the the makings and the telegraph you
know what's happening
turns out he was really right i mean
what a smart move
but um so they left before the coup
we left we left after the first
failed coup all right so there was there
was two coups what first one was like
you know oh okay about the tanks going
up the capital steps and like you know
military coup you know and then this
young general chavez you know young
military guy chavez you know and then he
decided to create a propaganda took a
page from almost
you know dictatorship out there and then
and then started promising the people
things that were just scientifically
impossible and the people started
believing it so then he launched himself
as the president and then got himself
voted in by the people
and then once he voted in he changed the
rules and stayed precedent for 15 20
part of that sounds unfortunately
familiar
um yeah
so so it makes it that much funnier that
when you came here the kids were like
you know your cousins you tell that
funny story about you know not
thinking that you didn't even know what
a school was so you're coming from this
like threat somewhat thriving place and
and um
what so what was the thing that struck
you when you got here uh that that was
diff what was the big difference um
between american kids american
society and and yeah venezuela
i think i think their their version of
what crime and violence was
was
was committed for a 14 15 year old kid
who grew up watching six o'clock news
the competitions and school buses
sprayed with machine guns and bombs
under schools and like
you know growing up in a world where you
know escobar was still much you know
empowered back in south america in
colombia you know so you come out here
and you're like this is the happiest
place on earth this really is disneyland
you know you come out here with a
perspective that
what what can possibly be so bad you
know and i was listening to
friends of mine at 14 15
16 years old you know talking about oh i
need my space like my mom and my dad
like smothering me and i need to like
move out and i need to like
in the delusional side of like that
that was the thing that i was like why
would you
you're only 14 years old like you're 15
years old and you're claiming you need
your space from your parents like what
you're going to do
go get a job and then start paying rent
and like i don't even understand like
you finish high school yet and you're
already talking about i need my space
i'm like what the hell is going on in
this world
well will i think that's that's
something that gets lost i know you know
elsa marie collins and you do stuff with
this is about humanity it's an
organization i love and that's something
that i think gets lost in that in the
immigration narrative which is these
people and i'm not saying this is true
of your family but you mentioned the
violence that you witnessed growing up
on the news and stuff so many of these
latin americans are escaping
they're good people who are escaping
these horrific conditions um
and i think that's something that
doesn't get uh
enough coverage but but you just
reminded me of of that reality yeah man
and and i think it's because you know
america uh in american media and news
media um you know it's it's uh it's
unfortunately
been programmed to follow trends
you know so when you follow the trend
you're not really reporting you are just
following what people
are in the mood to watch right now yeah
as opposed to the rude awakening enough
like let me raise awareness to this area
the reality more attention yeah my
reality and so so that was the first
thing man that i that i realized and i
think you know i mean look it was not
just kids man i think even some of my
teachers you know i
the the uh
the academic um
frequency in which you are taught back
in south america it's two
grades
um
at more advanced than the united states
so for example if i'm on
sixth grade in the united states my
sixth grade is teaching me eighth grade
level oh wow right in venezuela so when
i came to to the united states even
though i didn't know how to speak
english i was straight a student because
everything they were showing me from
like math to like value to all the
things that were kind of universal stuff
i had already seen two years before oh
my god so then how did you learn english
well uh while you're doing that did was
it about watching movies was it just a
murder like an immersion i think it was
you know the survival kicks in right and
you know that this is the thing you need
in order to survive
so it kind of goes into it but you know
even teachers justin used to think that
i was
cheating in my test
like how are you and they would isolate
me to take tests in the corner like so i
didn't so i couldn't copy oh my heat on
my test and i kept trying to explain in
my broken english which by the way
already perception is oh you're
uneducated because you're having such a
terrible accident right they're like how
are you making sense like why are you as
straight as
you you can't even speak the language
you know so imagine what a teacher says
that to a young
immigrant who comes here who is focused
who's doing his homework who's doing it
like how much more can i prove to you
that i am doing my part in this
classroom
you know and now even the teachers
assuming that you're cheating how what
does that do to you at that age i mean
when a teacher does that what does it
make you could you strike me as somebody
who would be motivated by that that it
wouldn't get you down that you would you
you've
always been so buoyant seeming and and
positive but can you kind of can you
recall what that felt like and and how
you responded to that i i chose i chose
to look at it as humorous uh-huh you
know i had a very really funny sense of
humor about all these things you know so
where did that come from
i think my dad you know i think my dad
my dad finds a way to crack jokes at
funerals
and you're just like he's that guy yeah
right he's like guy they're trying to
make he's trying to make the widow
laugh while the coffin is being lowered
and you're like dad
i don't understand you know i i really
believe and i've said this a million
times you might have heard me say this
before but if you woke up this morning
you're already
right so how much more winning do you
want to do today because it is a
constant decision in how you see today
today could it be a drag
or today could be enough another
opportunity to you know traditionally
and poetically like other people say to
do it better than yesterday right
so but but but it ultimately there is
time for everything in life and at that
time of my life i understood
that most people would not understand
because
they didn't grow up where i grew up yeah
so i had a level of
and again speaking of my feminine side i
think that the listening to the in
between the lines to the the listening
of you know that their actions were
telling me something else was
also made me more fascinated about
acting
like you know it was like the
exploration of how people say one thing
and they do another yeah you go oh
they're not mean they're just like this
is what they know and this is how they
express frostbite you know there's like
this the multi-layered thing that you
have technologically built
it's fascinating where did the where did
fez where did that come from where did
that voice come from i imagine it wasn't
written it wasn't
described that way in the script how
much of that was just you doing it i
they only gave me two pages to audition
for that seven show and um it was the
basement scene the the bullet runs on
water you know we're in the round table
downstairs and and you know i bring that
scene up because
there's no context you know the show had
no title right and show us at the time
was being called teenage wasteland you
know i don't know and so you didn't know
with the show really i didn't know the
show was on the took place in the 70s
the agents didn't get any kind of
breakdown or anything they said hey here
show up to this audition or whatever so
it's two pages of dialogue
what's the do you remember the
description of the character
it was just that he was going to be a
foreign exchange student um and they
didn't know what ethnicity so therefore
the time being they were going to call
him uh fes which stands for foreign
exchange student so then that's what
that that was the the the hook right and
they're like we don't know where he's
gonna be from yet until we cast the
person or the actor and then we give him
the name based on his origin ah i took
it as like
we don't know where he's gonna be from
so then i decided to combine accents
from different places around the world
and then i got big like you know like
the hardness of like a russian accent
and i had the list from spain and then
started adding like different things you
know that's fine
and i was like oh i can't even i can't
even the phrase where this accent may be
from you know so i thought oh that's a
cool thing i'll do it yeah you know like
an international collage that's right
and then what i did was that evening i
was playing around with my little sister
and i made this funny voice you know and
she started
uh laughing and every time i did the
voice i started laughing even more and i
said interesting so i married the voice
that i made when i was playing with my
sister stephanie
and
and then the accent and then i went and
auditioned with that the next day and
they and they lit i mean justin
i said
i said my first two lines and
the casting director goes
like she didn't even laugh she was like
i want you to come back tomorrow
what you did tomorrow
and
you know we'll see how it goes we just
come back to my way so she had my
audition for the producers of the show
the producers of the show were laughing
so hard
that he got to a point where i thought
they're laughing at me
they they hate me they hate me yeah yeah
like i'm a joke
you're like the guy in american idol
who's like it could go either way
they're either great they're terrible
oh this is normally the kid in american
idol
because it's a funny segment for the
people
yeah yeah and he's too confident
yeah yes like i'm like literally i got
you know i got the funny hat and i got
the boots you know whatever that but but
the point is i auditioned with that and
then they were laughing and then they
said okay thank you very much it brought
me back a second time for now the
creators right so at that point you got
to know i mean once they bring you back
in for
for somebody like that
you got to know that they're they're
serious about you yeah does that make
you more nervous does that change what
you're doing have they given you any
notes to adjust anything they're just
like keep doing it keep doing the same
thing you know and it was the same scene
so i kind of already know it by heart
and i remember going to the producers
call back and i was like oh it's a call
back i guess they're kind of liking what
i'm doing but i always was so used to
justin being like the alternative in a
lot of my auditions because there was
not a lot of roles for latinos back yeah
right so when i show up i remember you
know i was such a like i still am but
i'm i was such a like
cautious and educated and proper young
man at the time that when i saw topher
come in
and told for like
walked in open the refrigerator in the
lobby grab himself a water sit down open
it
and start talking i'm thinking like
that's pretty disrespectful like this is
not the stuff
you didn't even ask for that's really
funny that's so funny
yeah like that he's definitely not
getting it
he's being very impolite well i'm also
i'm laughing because i'm imagining i'm
thinking about how different you and
topher grew up like
especially the two of you like
you describe venezuela and you know not
having a certain thing and like tophers
from
darien connecticut is cool connecticut
yes yes just like yeah
this is my water you know and i'm like
oh you didn't even ask for it yeah
um but anyways
long story short man the most wondrous
moment was um
you know we they took me to network
audition
and you know they make you sign
contracts right before that right you
know for people that are listening may
not be uh familiar with uh with the
process when you go to a network
condition no our audience knows they
know
yeah they make you sign what like it
sold my audience they know what a
contract that's all we talk about
we just talk about the ins and outs of
the biz
um yeah yeah so
they give you the contract right
and you know you don't have the job yet
but they they say sign this contract you
get the part we don't do the paperwork
whatever basically they sign you before
you give me look you know at the
contract or whatever that was bad
network auditions you know
so i rooted the contract and he said
that i was going to make 15 000 for the
first episode and then ten thousand
dollars per episode
and i i started laughing
and i looked at it like i was holding
the powerball ticket right and i looked
at my dad like dad
imagine if i get this [ __ ] right now
this is going to be hilarious if i
that's like me
if you get it
very good if you don't get it
[Music]
i don't know
i did very good i was like okay dad very
good uh and i just thought look if i got
it good good if i didn't get it then
fine it's fine you know
anyways but i like your dad i like that
impression of your dad is that does he
have a uh
yeah he sounds like he's drunk all the
time but he's not he didn't drink too
much uh
today
how would he order what would he order
at a bar uh mr valderrama what would you
like
um
[Music]
the grilled cheese
what kind of cheese mr valderrama
you know what what whatever whatever
cheese that you want i want
the grilled cheese
tomatoes tomatoes on the side and
and the lady were just to be sitting
there waiting for the but my dad my
whole life like he kind of spoke english
but he kind of didn't he always
before he said the most simple [ __ ]
right so he'd be like
you'd be like uh
come here
let me tell you something let me tell
you something yeah yes dad you
uh-huh
yes papa
and
i'm playing you
and uh at uh
go shower
that's really funny
that's great do it i mean i mean just to
kind of finish that moment bro i well so
you go in there so you sign the thing
you're there you sign the thing and i
tell my dad i was like maddie if we get
this thing and i go in and then all of a
sudden
you know in the inside it's peter roth
bonnie and terry turner mike brazil you
know i mean that but literally everybody
had fox everybody of course yeah
and um there's like maybe 15 people
there the director and i mean everyone
and i am terrified because i was like
well you know what my dad said also if i
get it good if it i don't get it very
good you know so i went in there and did
the exact same thing and then i you know
i don't you know this was a very hard
week for us we were
late in the rent you know two months now
and
wow my dad had to choose
whether this gas money was going to take
me to this audition or he was gonna go
around a couple of errands for our
mechanic shops where you take this
mechanic parts from one shop to the
other
and instead of using the gas money for
that because i was a good student and i
had straight a's my dad decided to take
me to this call back
and you know we were eating dinner every
other night and you know we didn't cry
about this stuff this is like you know
just you know latinos when you know if
we eat dinner every other night you know
or things get a little rough you know we
don't complain we don't cry about it we
just turn the music a little louder and
you know there will be a food at some
point this week you know but so
my dad you know we
you know i told my dad this and this but
that's the advice he gave me and i went
in audition and
and uh you know i remember bonnie turner
at the back of the room and she just
stood up by herself and started clapping
wow it was the only one clapping and
then a couple of people clapped with her
and i was like thank you because where
are you from
venezuela venezuela okay all right so
thank you well thank you very much thank
you very much i just kept you know
creeping back to the door with my front
to them and my back to the door thank
you so much thank you so much
and i just left and then 30 minutes
later the agent called me and uh said
hey look good news they want you to uh
they want you to come back tomorrow and
i thought oh my god i got another call
back
and he said i i want you to they want
you to come back tomorrow and
the day after that
and the day after that oh well i got
chills
so
and my family's on the other line and
everyone starts crying and
15 000 is more than we've made probably
in two years
so immediately i said the only thing i i
got to do is not get fired at that pilot
you know and
and i just decided in that moment one
america i mean the united states of
america the line of the opportunity the
american dream immediately i looked
outside there was an american flag
waving up magically and poetically like
a movie and i just said to myself
i will never take one moment for granted
and everything i do on screen will be
the funniest [ __ ]
you've ever seen and that was the most
commitment make the most of that
and you know and i was able to take my
family instead of the 99 cent store
which we were going for a grocery store
we went to ralph's which was like you
know yeah all the brand stuff like it
wasn't cola it was coca-cola it wasn't
like uh you know it was it was so it was
a really exciting moment just to close
out this um
chapter in your life what uh
so you you you have moments where you're
spending but then
is it about taking care of family i mean
is that once that's done is it like
everything else is gravy
i mean there was a hard lesson i mean
there was a major heart lesson um and i
had to really understand priority right
because uh
you know you make that kind of living
you don't know when you'll make that
kind of living again and i knew that
when i played fest right like
what if this is the only role i ever do
you know
um and um
but there were some rude awakenings you
know it's also in the people you
surrounded yourself with you know i i
did the the mistakes of having the posse
and like you know having suvs waiting
outside you know for like 10 hours and
like dude you know it's like you're like
i always liked your posse though
yeah i had a good crew i had a great
yeah but you know it's also like
everywhere we went
there was two layers of other people
that would see opportunity for like yeah
the meal the trip the this and whatever
and um you know the rude awakening of
knowing that i was the only one reaching
for my pocket in many ways and i was it
was a it was a privilege right i loved
sharing people i love sharing with
people i love like i'll pay for dinner
i'll pay for this because i just i never
had it so i'm ready i know that and my
dad said to me when i was young food and
drinks are sacred if you can you know
you don't let anybody pay for that and
that's how i was raised but then when i
came to america topher uh taught me how
to split the czech
and he would make sure we split that in
half and half by the set okay yeah
life could be a dream sweetheart
hello hello
[Music]
i want to talk about how these other
projects in your life have worked into
that new mindset and starting with ncis
which is i didn't realize it's the
number one drama on tv
yeah i i didn't know that either oh
really okay maybe i'm making that up am
i making that up no no no it's real i
mean now i claim it right because i've
been on the show for a couple years you
know so now i can definitely confirm
that it is true you know
but uh but i will say um i had done this
pilot i didn't get picked up um
i guess the network and studio like what
i've done on that pilot and they decided
you know that i would be a good fit for
something that was about to happen that
that the world didn't know about i guess
michael weatherly was the ncis
and then they said um
we have to and at that time
you know the the representation
representation of of latinos and people
of color and television was something
that cbs had to improve uh majorly so
that you know so they had a conversation
with me about joining ncis and trying to
bring a different energy to the show and
like expand the show to a different era
and
and i at the time i was hesitant um but
then i talked to mark harmon and i
talked to the writers and everybody and
everyone who was so incredible and and
they were still coming to work and still
swinging and this was season 13
and then i finally um
you know i'm uh they're they're entering
well i said they're we are entering i'm
still i still feel like the new kid by
the way yeah i've spent five seasons you
know but
oh my god i've done five years on the
show i'm going into my sixth year in
their 19th season holy and [ __ ] and dude
they're we're averaging 10 million
viewers live every tuesday night um and
we are number one and 18 to 49 and you
know what that means in that demo so
it's like
it's really it's a unicorn you know and
i think it's the loyalty of the past the
audience is still watching love it and
and was there was there was it daunting
at all knowing that
because they broached it in that way in
terms of uh representation and
wanting there to be uh
more of a latino presence in
on tv
was it at all daunting knowing that you
would be
tasked with that that that would be part
of this foray into the ncis world
i i was on on a mission uh justin i i
really thought to myself you know well
this is an incredible challenge to go to
a network that is you know typically
been seen as you know such a
conservative uh um
network in content i should say i'm not
even talking about the audience the
audience the caucasian broadcasting
system yeah but yeah it was like it was
like a tv
thank you you read my mind yeah you know
but the but the the point is is that it
was such a dynasty you know and for me
to go to their number one show
um
you know was it was an exciting
challenge and
i always joked around that i went to
ncis to put a little coffee in their
milk
and that's funny
you know and and to kind of push those
characters to perform on a different you
know dynamic and energy and and the
writers were incredible they played with
me they understood where i was trying to
build and i feel the character that the
show has never seen before
uh and that was all in my strengths he
could be funny he could be terrifying he
could be dramatic you know um and so
they let you kind of tailor that
character i mean do they let you uh so
when you say coffee in the milk it's not
just an ethnicity thing i i hear that
and i think
you brought an energy that had it on
that show it's not just about being
latino it's it's who you are naturally a
a charming kind of
yeah and they that's why they wanted
your input
yeah and they were very open i got to
give them so much love for that because
they said what do you want to play we
make anything happen it's a beautiful
offer i mean i i actually was very
hesitant and that's these conversations
were the ones that made me feel like i
guess i can go and play and i so my i
did my first two-year contract so i'm
gonna do two years and see if you like
me here yeah
yeah you know we both will continue to
do it you know well it'd be funny if you
were like i've always wanted to play a
white guy just a boring
standard
just that straight down the middle
i didn't look i really i'm literally in
my career i'm really trying to challenge
myself and see myself more like a chris
pine type of type you know and i i
really feel like maybe even a british
accent i don't know what i'm trying to
do
you know maybe his name is brent
or brandon
brent could be you know be also said
with a heartbeat i don't know i'm just
spitballing here you know
but the point is that they really were
all paying right and that's cool they
just said you know how can we tell her
this to you and i told him all the
things i really wanted to do and but my
biggest thing was are you willing to
take the show where it's never been
before because the last thing you want
to do is come into a show that notes
itself so well and that it doesn't need
you because i rather go to a place where
i'm really needed and i just wanted to
create a shift a paradigm shift for the
show where he made it exciting for
everyone on the show yeah um and so yeah
so that's what it is and you know cool
the ratings came in the last you know
which is insane for me that the audience
is so loyal and so amazing to this show
man because dude i gotta tell you
you know they tune in every tuesday
we'll have like two reruns back-to-back
and then on the new one we come back and
it's 10 million viewers
live and then that's nuts you know and
then at the end of the week it's over 10
million right because of the dvrs
right sorry there must be people now
that recognize you as the ncis guy and
maybe aren't even aware that you were on
that 70s like two-thirds of the audience
didn't know i was fez on the seventh
ship
funny
yeah that was a very funny
thing to see that people some people
were discovering me as an adult on this
show i want to talk about blast beat and
trouble
and things that you're doing with your
production company you mentioned that
you're in the office now
does your production company have
anything to do with either of those
yeah i mean i am when it comes to
trouble we we produced that show from
scratch and that movie from scratch um
we just premiered one in a netflix as an
original netflix film called charming we
were top three uh wolf films and on
netflix which was a crazy surprise for
us and really exciting because we
we built that movie over the course of
four years
and to be able to have that movie
released was amazing i played the first
live prince charming and i cast all my
friends in it and then
um and then had like sia do the music
and like it was just an amazing
collaboration with a lot of friends
charming that's on netflix yeah and then
um and then a trouble is the next one
that's up it's a movie um i did with
lucy hale dan joe miguel myself and a
few other amazing friends that like
and lucy mchale yeah and then also we
have uh snoop dogg plays uh you know
it's old dogs by the way so he's over
man oh my god
so yeah so we're we're busy man and
excited and a lot of different
announcements happening in the next
three weeks that i i could not be more
excited for it oh wow do you want to
drop one on a big exclusive on life is
short oh yeah yeah
uh what can i say
so
uh robert rodriguez and i have partnered
up to it to executive produce he will
direct and i will start in uh in a world
war ii story of an old mexican infantry
unit
and during um doing world war ii the
army put all mexican infantry units and
they were the first ones dropped in the
front line of the river crossing the
rapido in italy during world war ii and
no one in the history of books have
actually talked about the fact that they
were all mexican infantry units and
there was a friend there in the front
line
yeah a hundred thousand five
huge casualties then i was just about to
cover that yeah i mean 125 uh soldiers
in this platoon only 25 survive of this
encounter and
it's one of the most heroic stories that
nobody's ever heard of you know wow this
temperature unit you know compiled of
you know
all mexican farmers painters
construction workers and all that stuff
sent to you know suicide mission and uh
you know so robert rodriguez and i are
about to exactly produce the story and
again this is the type of content i'm
doing with my company and trying to
rewrite a lot of our cultures back in
the book of history um to really kind of
remind all of us that you know we were
also there that we also wore the uniform
and that we fought side by side and we
had each other's backs at one point so
that's one major bond that i have i mean
the traits haven't even announced it yet
or anything but oh yeah it's called
patriots uh from the book patriots from
the barrio oh man that sounds incredible
well and what uh what a great way to use
your platform in this production company
to br you're right to bring to amplify
these like uh um moments in history that
i it's an amazing story i've never heard
of it and i like i love history um
and i thought i knew everything about
history
that's really cool we'll be on the
lookout um
uh lightning round really quick what is
your most commonly used emoji
um i think the um oh the the one that's
like the eyes that are about to cry but
they're not crying yet you know what i'm
talking about oh yeah they're watering
up they're filling up no why do we not
that that's my go-to for anything it
doesn't even have to match what somebody
said i just
oh brilliant people like what's going on
i'm like i would just don't reply right
after that that's like my last that's
how i end every conversation oh that's
that's funny uh if you could be i've
used that so infrequently i that's funny
if you could be a professional athlete
what sport would you play i think a
soccer player because i think it would
it would give my dad
he would give my dad a lot of joy but if
you ask me directly me like i would
probably be a ufc fighter i'd like to i
like to really
you know i love mixed martial arts and
that's something and i love ufc you know
so i think it it would have been cool to
you know to really go the distance and
see what it would take you know yeah
your dad lives in l.a
yeah he lives actually
i i have uh
a compound in the valley right and my
dad and i bought the neighbors house and
my mom my dad and my mom live in the
same property i mean so it's it's it's
an amazing feeling wow um if you could
have one snack food for the rest of your
life your go-to desert island snack food
oh yeah yeah snack food there's no
consequences you can eat it in a vacuum
you don't have any like health
consequences oh wow okay so i would
probably do
a loaded acai bowl like four times a day
whoa that's the healthiest uh
it's not really because i said load it
so you got to think about chocolate
chips nutella
you know honeydew so you gotta think
about you know it's like a hot fudge
sundae
it is it is
i do like um
what is your favorite movie sequel of
all time
ah man i think
i can i toss a coin and i think you're
gonna like one uh um
the the two that i love the most is the
rocky series and the back to the future
states
and it goes and that tells you a lot
about my life that's who i am you know
like the rocky story with like why not
follow the future you know yeah so yeah
um have you ever watched back the future
with topher
i mean i don't have to because he'll
just do it right thanks
and by the way
to all your fans on the show here too um
i'm sure you guys have seen it a few
times but justin also caused any
incredible impersonation of michael j
fox
well yeah i've done it i've had a
michael j fox off with topher and uh no
sir yeah it's really fun i gotta have
him on the show to do it um
what is your what is your go-to karaoke
song
my go to karaoke song would have to be a
matchbox 20 uh song
and the most depressing the better back
to good um and occasionally push because
i like straining my my vocal chords i'll
be able to speak afterwards but rob
thomas didn't you know because i love
matchbox twin it's like one of my
favorite that's when i was like when i
was a little younger and i learned how
to speak english to listening to
matchbox 20 and busta rhymes
oh so awesome
so then i became friends with both of
them and i was like my brain is melting
oh my god
you know yeah
buster you taught me engl it's funny
that's a he's a funny voice to learn
english from because he was very
articulate and he was very fast and he
really challenged you know
who was your first celebrity crush
oh my first celebrity crush that's easy
uh yes it could rabbit oh yeah
yeah
sure i mean it taught me so much about
how me as a man yeah
yeah i could never get over the fact
that she was a rabbit you know she had
those big rabbit feet
um
oh uh jessica rabbit yeah she had rabbit
feet
i didn't know that for why did i forget
that yeah well you probably blocked it
out so you could focus on other yeah
parts of it yeah i chose to see it
differently yeah otherwise there's all
bestiality element that you want to
ignore um if you had to get a tattoo
what would you get and and where on your
body
i would get my my daughter my first
daughter's name meccano um you know i
would get that will be the first time to
ever again um i'm not saying you're
going to have more kids but you keep
referencing her as your first daughter
and it just tells me that subconsciously
i i feel like for sure i mean i think
that i mean my lady and i definitely are
very open to you know to uh more babies
at some point you know but we're gonna
really enjoy this first one yeah and
then real and then figure out when it's
time to just like let's just get them
done yeah yeah let's just do a whole
bunch in a row uh what is your favorite
fruit
favorite fruit
oh man that's a that's a good question i
would have to probably say with uh
passion fruit uh oh yeah for the obvious
reasons yeah
i should note to the listeners that
wilmer gave me a very seductive look
just now um what uh who do you want to
play you in your biopic
um i would you know what
i had someone i was gonna say
but i am going to
i'm gonna i'm gonna do a curveball here
i'm going to say justin long
and the reason why i'm going to say
justin listen you got to listen to this
listen i've been waiting for a pocket in
this entire interview to put in this
anecdote and this is the moment okay
there was a time where people had um
uh greeting machines voicemails you know
people would leave themselves voice
notes i don't know if the young people
today can relate to a voicemail nowadays
you know all right but true
there was a time where justin long
left me a voicemail
as wilmer valderrama
and i played it to 300 people because it
was so
incredibly legit that she made me laugh
for three years i kid you not i
literally
that made me laugh so much do you
remember giving me that voicemail yeah
vaguely vaguely i gotta work i gotta
work on it i you know what i'll do is
when we do my brother and i will do the
outro and i'll try to do because i try
to
if it's a guest that has a unique voice
i'll try to do it um
yeah i mean it's not my accent now is
the one that i had then you know that's
why it was so brilliant
it's smoother now yeah
i was wondering if it it just from being
here yeah i mean like the more you speak
the more you you express yourself
eventually i think you start kind of
like it's like having a sandpaper you
know you just smooth out the edges a
little bit you know the accent is still
around you know but
but the accent that i had back then was
was very uh
distinctive
it was very like uh like you could hear
you can hear it now right
so you can hear when you hear like old
interviews and stuff
that it strikes you that oh my god it's
amazing it's
crazy it's a crazy different accent man
it's a whole different world you know
well wilma i i've noticed when i when i
go back in here some of those old
embarrassing interviews i i like sound
like more nasally and i have like a
higher voice i sound like nasally and
higher it's really weird um yeah who's
your favorite did you have the muppets
growing up in venezuela yeah yeah we had
the muppets uh we also had cars
uh now i sound like one of those kids in
school i'm kidding i'm kidding
we are at the muppets and uh we had
sesame street as well um
who was your favorite character
i don't know i was a kermit guy i think
yeah yeah yeah i mean like how could you
not and then there was uh i think the um
what was his name in i was in spanish
but i never remember his name in english
it was the the green guy in the trash
can oscar
oscar yeah oscar the grouch yeah what is
his name in spanish i think it i think
they call him something like they call
me
or something which is like the trash
eater or something like it was something
really weird
but every every region had a different
thing for their names but i think it
might have just been oscar the beatles
were the rolling stones probably beetles
yeah you have a song that
if you're at a bar you go to the jukebox
is there a song that you put in you want
to hear
uh i think come together with you know
it was one of my favorites the long
windy road uh that was great uh god uh
i've just seen a face
you know i dedicated i've just seen your
face yeah
[Music]
and then you know obviously you got to
do let it be and help you know the thing
goes to where i like it um seinfeld is
on and friends are on which one do you
watch
science bill i was a soundfield person i
think friends was iconic and really
funny i never really got into it though
and i love them all i think they're
great but i think steinfeld spoke to me
uh because of the silliness and the way
the characters were built out to be
bigger than life but still grounded
and real you know i think that's what i
love the most about them
um buddy i i've totally taken advantage
of your time uh but
that's why i let it happen
thanks man i forgot how fun it is to
hang out with you this was um i i want
more i want to see you thank you man and
and just can i just say
you have always brought so much joy to
my life every time you and i are in the
same
space
when i look back at the journey of my
life and my whole career
you know you were there for
the most exciting moments and you were
someone that i respected and looked up
to in many many ways i just think that
we need more of you on screen you know
i've definitely missed you man so
definitely definitely let's do let's do
the off the uh podcast
you know uh chats and then and then get
back get back in the group i would love
it uh you're making me cry i would love
it i i feel the same about you man i i
you are um always been such an honorable
good person good presence in my life so
thank you and thanks for doing this
[Music]
well wow that just happened that
happened
well you know the thing with him with
wilmer is he's like um he's
first of all i feel a little i used to
do it a lot as he said you feel like
cultural appropriation yeah but i i'll
tell you why you shouldn't feel that way
because he
directly
gave you permission yeah i guess so he
he just gave you permission i did it as
i do
all of the impressions i i enjoy doing
out of love i have a lot of affection
for him and you look very different than
he does when when you talk well yeah
he's very handsome you have like a much
looser face yeah a little bit more fishy
well yeah like a deepsea i wasn't going
to say that
you like loosen your jaw when you do
that impression and it's a little hard
to look at to be honest sorry well you
know when i i was doing the impression
with him and i pitched him this idea i
said
you know would be funny for the 70s show
because it was on at the time if fez had
a friend from back from wherever he's
from come to visit him and so this guy
would be even more foreign than fez
would look up to him for being kind of
americanized it was a funny idea so i
appreciate that and wilmer liked it and
um and a couple years later i got a call
from my agents and they were like yes
the strangest thing a call came in
uh saying that you had talked to the 70
show people and they want you to do an
episode and so i agreed to do it didn't
read the script i just imagined it was
that character which i thought would be
fun to do i guess the whole joke the
running joke with fez is that no one
ever knows where he's from it was a
runner throughout this series
[Music]
and so my character was written to be
very stereotypically british you know
looking back also i was thinking about
that character about fez that you
couldn't do that now no like that that
was a pretty
i mean it wasn't offensive at the time
certainly but it was it kind of was well
i would argue it wasn't offensive
because the way wilmer played it with so
much humanity and
it was done in a very good natured way
and he wasn't dumb he was naive and he
was an innocent
yeah i mean he was extremely naive and
extremely innocent yeah to the point
where
you think it'd be offensive it suggests
that
americans from is right like
less development yeah yeah less advanced
i'm not offended by it but i well you're
not well maybe i don't think they could
have that character
on a show today that's interesting do
you think that's why they never
they never were specific about where he
was from that was the quote-unquote joke
but really it was to protect them from
offending a particular nationality maybe
that was a really uh touching story he
told about getting the part and
his family being behind him supporting
him
uh whether he'd gotten it or not and how
like what a difference that money
i know like the idea of fifteen thousand
dollars i know
to that family yeah um compared to
topher's family i was thinking and isn't
it funny but it's just it's like moving
to know
what a huge thing that was i know and
like how much it changed not only his
life but his whole family's life and now
his parents
live yeah on his property he developed
them the house next door i mean it's
really he's clearly a very generous like
good person he's always been like that
and he alluded to this a little bit it's
it's even gotten him in trouble i mean
he's
he's been so generous that i think
people have taken advantage of that it's
funny that's the topher story oh i love
it it made me laugh so hard because i
pictured it me too i'm just like
strolling into the waiting room like
opening the fridge pulling out of water
and teaching them how to split a check i
know you know topher and i were um were
really good friends back in the day we
should try to get him on the show we
should i i like him as an actor we hung
out with him
um in connecticut once remember i sure
do thanksgiving uh it was around
christmas christmas yeah i remember we
went to his house to his parents house
and they in darien and they had um they
just put up their christmas tree shout
out to the blue wave i thought you're
gonna say shout out to the graces oh
yeah they're very nice people they were
nice people sister's great yeah and who
else is from darien oh kate bosworth and
katie goodman
oh a couple katie's yeah that we know do
you remember we went out with topher and
his sister for
uh to some bar in the canada indiana yep
and we had a really fun time all like
hung out all night yeah the four of us
had a really great time and at the end
of the night you
went to give him a hug goodbye
and i just met him that day but i
figured like i felt like we had really
hit it off and connected and had like
shared a lot of experiences
and
i went to give him a hug too and he
pulled back really aggressively and said
whoa
whoa
whoa uh
we just met today so oh my god
and i thought like my instinct was
he must be kidding it must be a joke
that he's reacting that way
but
i don't think he was it would be good to
have him on the show because there's i
want to ask him about his name his
name's christopher yeah and
i forget why he went by topher he i
think he explained it that night that
night he didn't want to hug me if it
makes you feel any better he uh
he got miffed with me oh it was also
kind of your fault because he invited me
to a star wars uh screening up at the
lucas ranch oh right and i canceled on
him at the last second because you were
coming to town for the first time you
came down for the first time right and
you think he held that against me he
never really i don't think he ever
really
forgave me totally for it that we should
have him on the show and talk about it
oh yeah oh that'd be fun to talk about
also it'd be fun to do dueling uh
whenever i see him we do he does have a
good he does
i've heard it he does wilmer
it made me laugh when he couldn't
remember oscar the grouch's name and he
called him the green guy in the trash
can
it also made me laugh
when you
very confidently said that jessica
rabbit had rabbit feet okay okay
i think you said you know i could never
get past those big rabbits okay
okay i'm excited that you brought this
up because uh it's very rare that i'm
confident about being right about
something
and you're equally confident about me
being wrong why are you so confident
about this when was the last time you
saw who framed roger rabbit because i'm
telling you right now you're wrong it
made an indelible impression in my mind
you're thinking of something else i
think you're thinking of
maybe made marion
in robin hood she was a very attractive
cartoon fox did jessica rabbit have a
tail
what made jessica rabbit a rabbit
do you want me to show you you looked it
up no oh okay i still think i'm right
i
i think jessica rabbit by the way if
anyone's still listening i'll tell you
what roger rabbit was a rabbit yeah of
course
but but what so you think jessica rabbit
was just nicknamed i think just
jessica rabbit because she got married
married roger rabbit got the name rabbit
oh my god but she was just like a vampy
sexy lounge singer wasn't she she was
diaz in the mask
oh they're similar characters
okay wait jessica rabbit or um sound i
hear some backtracking in your voice no
no i okay here we go google no but you
might i mean that makes sense that a
human would marry a rabbit oh weird look
at these rabbit feet
wait a minute
no rabbit feet human feet she was a
human a fully full-on human well she was
a cartoon
oh wait a minute that's why everyone
talks about her as being so attractive
uh-huh
oh i'm
what you must you must be thinking of
something i'm googling jessica rabbit
feet
jessica rabbit's feet you're gonna get
me on some weird cartoon foot fetish
list
wait what am i thinking of
jessica rabbit didn't have rabbit feet
what the [ __ ]
i thought she was like
there's no santa claus oh i feel like
such an idiot i never really got that
she so she was a human who just married
a rabbit yeah uh wow what am i thinking
of i have an image of like her taking
off her shoes it was a dream i had
that's weird you have to contact you've
never heard and apologized for
not giving him the wrong information but
like planning ruining his first crush oh
that's right you were like i could never
get past and you accused him of
bestiality
i did wait a minute wait a minute that's
really funny
that's really embarrassing i was the
only embarrassing part is how much you
want to shame me i know it's from these
dots and it's hot in here
what am i thinking of
maybe maybe another question it might
have been made i i found made marion
very attractive when i was a kid
me too and i found robin hood you both
had to be attracted to maine mary in the
animated cartoon made me and robin hood
was so cool
yeah of course does everyone think that
does every i don't know i thought all
robin hood's right harold flynn was cool
uh it's weird when you read about errol
flynn being such i never really had an
opinion about eric
flynn
he was a drunk pervert wasn't oh yeah
one of the drunkest pervious of all time
wow yeah well let's read a letter
from caleb davis
subject not fanboying over here well
trying
that's an interesting subject i'm
intrigued
caleb says dear justin and christian
2021 has really shaken up my world
my
wife my wife of 13 years passed away
suddenly in february at the age of 42.
oof
god it's been hard
42 yes
it's been hard not only for me but also
for our boy
wow
for our three kids it's been hard not
only for me but also for our three kids
who are 13 11 and 8. oh my god i am so
sorry to hear that caleb
as close as it is
to me i can't imagine what it's like
losing your mother like that dealing
with loss is hard but i'm seeing how
being open and present about it is not
only helpful but therapeutic the way you
interact and communicate not only with
the guests but with each other is
inspiring to me
listening to the random voice memos at
the end of each show that can seemingly
be about anything whatsoever sometimes
even nothing whatsoever help me see the
value of passing moments on
and not passing them over
i'd like to be better about
intentionally passing moments on for and
with my kids by getting over my dread of
hearing my own voice
thank you for that
man
so would you rather okay
um
yeah
that's intense that's intense and uh
uh beautiful in a way really yeah
uh so would okay caleb's would you
rathers
have garfield as a pet cat which in turn
leads to a borderline schizophrenic
personality arguably like john
or
yeah
john was probably really messed up from
that it's been hard to live with
garfield i mean if garfield were real
it's
and i think it was abusive
i'll be smacking him and
or
have hobbs as a pet cat
which in turn also leads to a similar
dissociative personality arguably like
calvin might have if he were to ever
grow up and maintain the same
relationship with hobbes um okay so
those are the witchy rathers have
garfield as a pet cat which internally
uh or have hobbs as a pet you know i
don't really know calvin and hobbes that
well oh you don't explain what hobbs is
hobbs is a more much more philosophical
calvin and hobbes had like
um
it wasn't nearly as
abusive hobbs was
i guess getting into
trouble but i think calvin was the more
oh really i thought hobbies was more
like tigger
like full of energy and
am i remembering that i think you might
be conflating tigger but now maybe i'm
not you know i don't trust myself after
that jessica rabbit feet thing
so i don't know i i'm much more familiar
with i love calvin and hobbes but it's
been a while since i've read them and
garfield was a lot more simple the
dynamics were simpler to me
uh i think
i i would rather have hobbs you would
yeah because garfield um
was also really like even though he was
fat and lazy he was like still pretty
needy and and he was like kind of a i i
read it recently to our nephew and um
and i didn't realize it occurred to me
now with like my adult
glasses on how
abusive garfield was really oh yeah in
fact i stopped reading it because i was
like oh
i mean he enjoyed it i don't know if you
enjoyed it but i didn't want to
it was i think he was probably picking
up some stuff yeah it's been so long
just constantly hitting odie and like
doing really well things i was going to
say
i loved garfield when i was kid but odie
not to say he deserves to get hit he was
annoying he was annoying normal wasn't
annoying normal was just like kind of
getting hit normal
no he didn't was weren't they like
boyfriend girlfriend no no no garfield
did have a girlfriend i forget its name
but nermal was like compete he competed
with nerd oh really
because normal was so cute
god i don't remember that he he was he
was just really uh he was kind of a dick
he was yes but he was wasn't he kind of
funny it was kind of sardonic and he'd
be like yeah well
don't let the door hit you on the way
out after like odi's got like his head
through a door here's a question yeah
so i guess i would pick hobbs then not
know how much you would like hobbs i
think because they would have uh
like kind of
life conversation interesting
conversations yeah but you don't get to
there's something spiritual about hobbs
and calvin and hobbes relationship all
right well i'll pick hobbs then yeah um
do you identify more with garfield or
odie i thought you're saying gonna say
heathcliff um
oh that's a good question
um
ah that's a good
i you know 10 years ago i would have
said odie for sure i can't believe you
you have to think about this but you
think it's odie yeah i know but like i
just say you're annoying excellent but
i'm saying compared what if i was like
actually normal
uh no i i think now they're i think
because i smoke more pot too now and i
get you know when i'm stoned it's
garfield oh it's garfield that didn't
smoke pot no but he was like he ate a
lot yeah
how great would lasagna be when you're
stoned
yeah imagine mom's lasagna
hi um
uh this is you sound like a weed dork i
know i never know how to say stoned
smoke imagine that when you're high
imagine shoveling that into your face
when you're high
man i got the munchies you got the
supreme munchies
you want to satisfy those cravings from
the old ganja
little doobie tv scooby we were watching
the office the british office uh
scooby-doo
um
and then caleb goes on to say it's great
would you rather it's funny we were
talking about garfield uh a couple weeks
ago yeah the president versus the kid
and um
yeah james garfield
i like i have a softer spot for garfield
because i know him better but i guess i
would pick hops oh i thought you were
going to say garfield cat versus the
president um yeah i would pick cobbs too
uh i wasn't i wasn't as aware of
heathcliff but i know heathcliff was
really into like fish skeletons wasn't
heathcliff just like an alley cat it was
like
of dr pepper yeah kind of yeah it was
like a gobot to the transponder yes um
afterward caleb says after reluctantly
got tripped up on that after reluctantly
it's a tough one after reluctantly
conceding my concern over sesame street
versus muppet characters i get it they
can all be in the same conversation i
have to say pepe the king prawn is my
favorite okay
you know i was thinking about this
character the other day i don't know
pepe
pepe pepe the king prawn
that well but the sight of him always
makes me laugh
yeah he's funny-looking funny-looking
it's a really great design i love that
character caleb says life is short is
very impactful to me and i can't thank
you enough for doing it so well
but thank you caleb um god what a nice
god letter damn that was really nice and
uh
uh obviously we are
i mean what do you say
what do you say there's nothing you can
say nothing to say but but we're
grateful that you
find any
find joy and value in this because we do
find or in anything right now i know i
know i can't imagine i can't even begin
to imagine what you're going through no
uh february she passed away we're so
sorry and um
we're grateful to you for listening and
for uh all of you for listening but um
and if you would like to write in our
email addresses life is short at
wandery.com
and uh thinking about your kids to uh
same age as as we were uh thirteen
eleven and eight the same i thought you
meant
yeah at some point
in our lives we were yeah we were all
those ages oh yeah that's that's true
wishing you guys the best and uh
and thanks for listening to this into
wilmer and to wilmer and to lindsay and
the whole valderrama and the lohan
family yes most of them
and one more shout out whoa
bob's pickle pops oh
yes bob's pickle pops looked them up
there i talked about them before on the
show but he just sent me more okay stuff
that i've been enjoying very much they
are delicious
they're like
imagine a delicious frozen
um
like dessert pop right you love those
things you're always but
it's
the flavor of pickle juice delicious
salty
yet refreshing
pickle juice
i am addicted to that i gotta tell you
it's it you have to just try them
because it doesn't sound like something
you want to have in fact we you
reluctantly tried them i said that i did
and i was i was as wrong as you were
about jessica rabbit i
can't believe that i can't believe mike
look at his bob's pickle pops they're
amazing okay yes yes and while we're
doing this uh free advertising uh honey
mama's has a new flavor cherry hazelnut
delicious
by the way i think the best flavor it's
really good cherry hazelnut um made with
uh gm non-gmo organic coconut meat okay
also thanks to our guest today i know
another things uh check out all that
he's doing he talks about it but he
talks about it on instagram and um you
can also see pictures of his adorable
new daughter wish them the best and
thank you to everyone for listening
we'll talk to you next week
life could be a dream
life could be a dream
life is short is hosted by me
justin long it is uh co-hosted and
produced by you christian long and it's
also produced by megan the monaco
senior producer is michelle miche lans
audio engineer is sergio enriquez
executive producer is marshall
we for wondering
[Music]
hello
looking to belong to somebody
looking for somebody to cuddle up on
maybe you think you have what it takes
to be my next pet
are you a ferret a dog a goldfish
there are no wrong answers
you just have to have a heart
and the ability to
let somebody touch you and pet you
oh hey there
almost didn't see you come in
do you have what it takes to be my next
special tab
well if so
leave a comment below in the section
that says comments
do you like to be told when to defecate
and when to urinate if so you might have
what it takes to be my next pet wow
there's some variations you have scales
fur feathers perhaps it doesn't matter
you just have to dedicate and urinate in
a designated spot
guys
oh gentlemen
i'll have you know that the submissions
have now been closed
you